i reckon that not one in a million
americans knows the following fact that
um 11 to 12 million slaves were probably
brought across the atlantic from africa
during the slave trade the transatlantic
slave trade
about 18 million africans were similarly
sold by their neighbors and others uh in
the slave trade that went east
so why do we not know about the 18
million slaves that went east from
africa um because there's no remnant of
them because the arabs castrated all the
men
does as i say does one in a million
americans know that context this that
that
slavery happened everybody was involved
in it it was a horrible thing then it's
a horrible thing now and it's still
going on now
um i've met slaves myself people who've
been born into slavery in africa
um and
i don't think anyone knows this and so
everyone's got the context all that
sorts
all right i'm dave rubin and we are on
location
in my house because i think that counts
as the location i think it does yeah
there you go and i am with my friend and
multiple author you've written 800 books
if i'm not mistaken
but your new book his new book is right
here it is the war on the west
douglas murray how are you my friend
great great to be with you again 800 how
many no i think this is number seven
numbers it's a little overshooting
number seven but my team told me this
morning that this officially today marks
your ninth appearance on the reuben
report ninth yes and there is some
debate as to whether you have now tied
gad sad for number two at nine where
there's a question there's one little
question related to if he's actually
eight or nine depending on which way you
want to count jordan peterson is 10 but
you are you are solidly second so and i
was your what second
guest ever you were yeah you were like
my second or third guest back in 2015.
we're still doing it
however my friend there is a war on the
west yeah
this country is burning see how i did
that with my book too very very clever
um
so let's sort of start with that you
know for all the years that we've been
talking about all of this stuff that now
is known as wokism which you write about
obviously but all of the culture wars
and all of the things that are happening
should we have been yelling louder say
seven years ago when we all started
talking about this this loose group of
people that were kind of signaling did
we miss something and maybe should have
been screaming louder or
was it going to happen no matter what
i think it was going to happen no matter
what i i learned from the years i was
writing about
islamism that you can spend 23 hours a
day
dealing with a subject but if you're
dealing with fanatics they're spending
24 hours a day doing it you just can't
you can't win in a way against fanatics
in the short term
and what we've realized in recent years
is that the let's say the woke
bandwagon these people are
radicals they're extremists they're
fanatics they have an extraordinary
set of claims and they have just managed
to push them bulldoze them right into
the
center of all of our lives and as
they've
as that movement has sort of crept
closer and closer to people people
realize that there were no
effective barricades
i mean i say in in the book that you
know there was a sort of for instance
there was a conservative idea which was
mistaken which many people including
myself i had in recent years which was
for instance that things like the
critical race theory the
intersectionality all of this crab
that it would stop at the borders of the
stem subjects it would say it would
never it would never take over
engineering it would never get into
medicine
you know
you mean it would never tell us that two
plus two equals five exactly you know
there's an assumption that you know okay
they'll do this with with the liberal
arts they'll do this with political
science and stuff but they won't do it
with engineering and the joke because
you know it was always well at some
point the bridges have to stay up
and then
they say no it turns out we'll see it
turns out they don't yeah
if the bridges come down now it'll be
because we live in a cis heteronormative
patriarchal racist society which has
institutional racism which is why the
bridge fell down
uh
so it's it's just flooded across
everywhere and um
and there's always that question of
whether you could have done more or
shouted more or whatever but
um
i think that a lot of people didn't
realize the scope of what was coming at
us
you have the line that i've quoted
probably 50 times on twitter and 50
times on my show and probably on other
people's shows that i think perfectly
encapsulates what's going on here which
is that one day you said this to me
probably five years ago one day the
barbarians will be at the gate and we'll
be debating what gender pronouns to call
them yeah does that really sum up almost
exactly where we are and that really
sort of gets to the title book that we
really are at a societal war right now
and instead of really focusing on what's
going on we are debating trans swimmers
yeah and
women with penises and the rest of this
yes yeah i know i mean it is it is
deranging and after i wrote about
what i regard as being this sort of
crowd arrangement in my previous book in
the madness of crowds i could see
already that this was this was happening
it was getting worse and worse people
were being
it was people were being demanded to say
things they knew not to be true
um
and and now it's got to a stage beyond
that i always thought that that thing
with that i described in the madness of
crowds was was a sort of step towards
something
that you know that the
say the
guy with a penis is a girl or
you know you're a bigot that and i think
i may even have said it to you that it
was it was almost like it was preparing
us for something because i always
maintained at the time if you if you
assault
uh the the basic things we know to be
true like the fact that there are boys
and girls and women that you're not
assigned to sex at birth as if it's a
sort of lottery uh system which if
you've got a particularly bigoted
delivery nurse you know she's just kind
of you know it's not that's not how it
works there are there are boys and girls
and and it but but that if if you
persuade people that that's not true
you can do an awful lot afterwards
because
you've made people doubt things the the
things they were absolutely certain
about you know the the cry now it's like
well you know how do you know i mean
you're a biologist and as a a fine uh
british feminist said to somebody the
other day uh said well i'm not a vet
either but i know what a dog is um so
yeah exactly it's like but but a lot of
people have been brow beaten and karen
and and i think that what i'm trying to
describe here is what i think is the
next stage of this
which is a war on the fundamentals of
everything in our society
a war on our history a war on our past
the war on our foundations
warn our culture
and a war on the people in the culture
what i described as a war on white
people which is a phrase that a lot of
people will sort of jump at but
there's there's no other way to describe
it now lots of different bigotries exist
in the world but the only one that's
completely tolerated and indeed
encouraged in 21st century america is
hatred of and diminishment of people for
being white we wouldn't tolerate it with
any other skin color we wouldn't
tolerate it if people said that black
people should be treated differently
because of their skin color
only white people is this now
permissible with and that's because
white people are
the inheritance of the west they're
portrayed as the people of the west who
must therefore pay
for the sins of the west you know it was
funny i was watching in the last couple
weeks a movie there will be blood did
you happen to see it with daniel
day-lewis about about the gold rush well
not the gold rush the oil rush and going
west in the 1800s into the 1900s and
it's you know it's a lot of white people
doing horrible jobs
horrible jobs in the coal mines and
digging and things collapsing on them
and people dying and fires and all of
these things
and it was making me think boy
we talk about the history of this
country as if these white people first
off as if they built all of this stuff
in honor of whiteness which is which is
completely insane completely insane and
not true even even in an iota of a
percent but also that these people who
happened to be white who built stuff
often was very dangerous and lots of men
were dying in the process well i mean i
give i give a number of examples of this
there are two there are two original
sins of the west that are seen now
slavery and empire
both are portrayed as if nobody else in
the world did them yeah
which is nonsense there were no slaves
before america right i mean
you know
almost if i reckon that not one in a
million americans knows the following
fact that
um 11 to 12 million slaves were probably
brought across the atlantic from africa
during the slave trade the transatlantic
slave trade um about 18 million africans
were similarly sold by their neighbors
and others uh in the slave trade that
went east
so why do we not know about the 18
million slaves that went east from
africa
um because there's no remnant of them
because the arabs castrated all the men
does as i say does one in a million
americans know that context this that
that
slavery happened everybody was involved
in it it was a horrible thing then it's
a horrible thing now and it's still
going on now
um i've met slaves myself people who've
been in spawn into slavery in africa
um and
i don't think anyone knows this and so
everyone's got the context all out of
sorts and the other one of course is is
empire and again these things are these
things are talked about as if no no
other
nobody else did this
you know
countries across the world tried to form
or did form empires
if you're going to get the sense of the
british empire into context you've got
to understand that if you want to get
the history of the transatlantic slave
trade into context you've got to
understand what else was going on
and as you say that crucial thing that
but it's not like everybody in the past
in the west was like living in clover
you know during the the latter stages of
the um of the slave trade the
transatlantic slave trade the average
life of a man working in one of the
mills in one of the towns in the north
of england was about 37. wow they lived
into their late 30s
people on slave plantations lived longer
now i'm not saying that the slave
plantations were good or anything like
it of course not i'm just saying like
can you honestly look at this and think
that those
those white if we must say that men in
the northern english mill towns were
free
did they actually have any any or much
agency in their lives did they have
control of their lives were they were
they privileged no
not at all
and it's a grotesque thing of our time
that we've decided that we've got to
pretend that these people were wildly
privileged as well as bigoted if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell